Netflix special is coming out Nikki
Glaser banging you excited about this so
excited about it what what I've decided
to do with this special is really get
across the messages that I've been
wanting to tell men but I'm too scared
to tell it to their face because it's
hard to communicate so this is kind of a
special for you know girls to put on and
like laugh really hard to let their
boyfriends know like oh yeah you
shouldn't me when I'm dry like that's um
that's mainly the big problem we're
getting when we're driveway too much
it's an epidemic facing this nation it's
I mean even my gynecologist uses lube
and I do feel insulted when she does I'm
like I can get there like tell me how
much you make a year but she even she
[Applause]
yeah yeah if this kind of air is this is
this is like a family Network we have it
it's all very helpful yeah very very
public health tips yeah and I and I have
a whole thing about which I can you even
say that going down I have a whole thing
about going down on women where guys
need to be doing it more and a lot of
guys like think that they can just be
like no I don't do that and it's like
well why and then really gonna really
like and I'm like do you think I like
doing that to you and having my throat
poked and like sounding like I have
strep throat all week because I like you
it's like no I don't enjoy that so you
do it to me too
I really have a whole bit about like you
need to be Conan I'm so sorry
no you're not
[Applause]
I'm learning a lot yeah yeah
Andy's learning I watch it I'm gonna
write down notes as I watch it back
posit yeah yeah second okay is that a
yes or a No - the last thing you have to
be you have to be in girls are ways like
how do I tell my boyfriend how do I do
it and if there's this weird thing that
you can do it's very subtle when they're
going down on you just just um just go
suck my
[Laughter]
okay well this is my final show Nikki
Glaser banging hey listen by the way
when you have Nikki Glaser on the show
this is what you get yes oh you're not
sorry you're not disrespecting my show
you're educating a very uptight Catholic
boy about how the world is changed